aux abords du port de beyrouth le chaos
et le silence succède au vacarme des
explosions de mardi dernier
ce vendredi quatre corps ont été sortis
des décombres les disparus se comptent
encore par dizaines mon cousin et sa
femme ont disparu mon cousin s'appelle i
mazza ed din
il travaille en tant que gardien au port
il a disparu depuis l'explosion
mon frère ibrahim ali amin travail dans
les silos de céréales nous ne l'avons
plus revu depuis trois jours pour
fouiller les décombres
l'aide est internationale l'union
européenne a débloqué 33 millions
d'euros en urgence
washington plus de 12 millions d'euros
paris envoie des avions et des équipes
de secouristes de médecins des efforts
coordonnés avec ses voisins allemands et
italiens des aides de l'iran des émirats
arabes unis et de l'arabie saoudite
arrive aussi à beyrouth
rome a déjà livré plus de huit tonnes d
aide médicale tandis que la russie
montrent un hôpital mobile pour
désengorger ceux de la capitale
au cours de la journée de travail d'hier
nous avons malheureusement retirer les
décombres trois corps de personnes
décédées
aujourd'hui nous avons repris le travail
à 5 heures du matin l'accueil des
patients l'hôpital mobile se poursuit
vous voyez l'hôpital fonctionne de 8h à
21h
aujourd'hui vent à 25 personnes
attendent la traitement en mode
ambulatoire
alors on a deux zones de recherche
principal celle ci était la première
étant donné la proximité par rapport au
lieu de l'explosion
on sait qu'il ya des personnes qui
travaillaient sur zone ça nous a donné
raison puisque on a trouvé des personnes
et une deuxième zone en centre-ville
directement
la perdre la zone la plus touchée de la
ville par rapport à l'explosif dans le
centre ville justement la mobilisation
est aussi citoyenne de nombreux libanais
s'organisent pour déblayer et nettoyer
les rues et pour porter assistance à
ceux qui en ont besoin
il n'y a rien à dire la seule chose à
faire est que chacun essaye d'aider là
où il le peut c'est peut-être la seule
petite chose que les gens peuvent faire
descendre et nettoyer les rues aider à
ramasser le verre brisé
déblayer les décombres quoi que ce soit
tant que nous aidons les uns les autres
et que nous sommes solidaires nous
sommes en train d'envoyer des gens dans
les maisons endommagées des personnes
âgées des personnes handicapées pour les
aider à trouver un logement pour ce soir
et nous essayons de les aider à nettoyer
leurs maisons afin qu'elle puisse
retourner y vivre
beyrouth doit maintenant renaître de ses
cendres
en parallèle du travail des secours une
enquête a été ouverte par la justice
libanaise pour déterminer les
responsabilités dans cette tragédie